thrilled to have here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is a
basketball hall of famer whose
professional career
in the nba began mere months after my
broadcasting career began at espn and
the number of highlights i called with
him
of him
um sitting next to stu back in the day
he loved this guy he's the legend he is
basketball hall of famer ray allen on
the rich eisen show brought to you by as
well abbott's freestyle libri 2 and new
freestyle libre 2 iphone app to help
manage diabetes in a 24 7 way good to
see you ray allen and chat with you
always rich
you brought me down memory lane because
i i remember that
uh just watching your career it
certainly paralleled mine because it's
you know some times gone by but you know
games have been called and won in in the
last 25 years and we've definitely
shared space we definitely shared space
and of course me being there in bristol
connecticut and you being a connecticut
legend a yukon legend
um it was just a big moment to for you
to be drafted you know by the
timberwolves in the first round you know
and um and then watch your career
blossom
um and it was just you know i don't know
memory lane right no question about it
so it is good to chat with you and it
was great to see you uh you know at the
the hall of fame with paul pierce what
was that like for you ray
um the hall of fame is like a high
school reunion uh now for us you know i
remember like one of the first events i
i was going to
and i was telling my kids the story
about one of the first games i went to
uh in l.a against the piston back in 88
and kareem abdul-jabbar was on the floor
shooting
and then we're at this dinner hall of
fame dinner and he walks in
and you know i'm already retired and you
know
around professional life for so long and
he walks in a room and you're thinking
you know i'm trying to get my content
like kareem just walked in look it's
kareem
and so it never gets old when you go to
the hall of fame induction weekend and
you see a lot of guys you played with
and against
uh you get to talk about games at the
end of the day you know it's it's it's
fascinating to be able to share space
with these guys because
you know you just played a game for a
living but what matters more is the the
time you spent
your families got to know each other
seeing kids grown up
um
it's just a special experience that
you know you cherish and you get that
once every weekend in the summer and
you know it's every year it's going to
be something new and you know it's
forever now what's it mean though to be
there and a teammate goes in though a
guy that you won a championship you you
hoisted the lario b with and paul pierce
you know it's it's um
i think it's it's somewhat
humbling because you know a guy you
played with goes in and you realize
you say to yourself like oh so we were
really good we were really that good
because you don't think about
being the hall of fame when you're
playing but afterwards
when you start to sum it up you're like
and on that team was three or four hall
of famers you're like yeah we should
have won the championship how many
should we have won because you know
history after it tells its story it will
come back and tell the story of how
great of careers that that you and your
teammates had that
ultimately
you know it set you apart from everybody
else and you know yeah i would have
loved to win more
while i played but at the end of the day
we won once i won once in miami and and
that was enough to just kind of for me
put icing on the cake in my career yeah
ray allen here on the richardson show
you know i referring to paul pierce
could have easily been referring to
chris bosh as well
going in in that class and
you know there
it's kind of front and center as well
right now ray with tom brady returning
to new england this weekend and how he
left and you know whether there's uh
hard feelings and when everybody can
come together where does that all stand
with you
uh you know obviously you and pierce are
cool where does that all stand with you
and the rest of the celtics team
you know well you know i i've said you
know from the moment i left like it was
a
great opportunity for me uh as my career
was uh winding down
um when you go through free agency you
have to figure out the the best uh
uh
spot landing uh going forward
and uh
you know it was only for me at that time
it was only so many uh possibilities and
so as as we moved forward it was
you just assume that
everybody
wishes you well and
you know people hate to see you go you
know i've been traded you know
before um
and
you just know it's a business it always
is the teams that trade you're always
going to trade you because they think
that you know bringing
somebody else in for you a couple people
or just one is better for that team
going forward and so you always know
it's a business
and at that point for us
you you think the same way like we got
to figure out the best way we can to you
know have a soft landing spot where we
have to put ourselves in a situation to
win so
um i i've never had any bad blood um i
do
get that sentiment from uh some of my
past teammates and from you know
people in boston but i think that is
spurned by you know
certain players still you know having
animosity
um and i i made
um
connection to you know like the pistons
and when they won in uh 2004 they
forever chop it up with each other and
they keep it going that's
whenever you win that's what it should
be all about and for me at some point
it's got to get to that that we've won
together
and we've grown together we've lost
together and you know winning the
championship always keeps you connected
and keeps you bonded and that should be
what we should be talking about ray
allen here on the rich eisen show um
basketball hall of famer and ray you
know now doc rivers as we know is in
philadelphia and he's got a player that
says he's done there in ben simmons and
we could go back and forth as to as to
what's going on there um but essentially
the the the simmons story is
um not his inability to shoot but on
occasion his his
lack of want to shooting and or lack of
confidence and i'd love to ask you one
of the greatest shooters of all time did
you ever
lose confidence in your shot does does a
a pure shooter ever lose confidence in
his shot
ray allen
um i i never lost confidence in my shot
i think it was more about the
opportunity to shoot
because when you're in situations
sometimes you you
um
you do have that opportunity to remove
from you in certain situations
um
he
uh ben is such a young player
with such a huge upside
uh the thing that i know about shooting
is i i remember a time when i couldn't
shoot
so
from that time to till i got to college
and then from there on in i understood
what it was that i did going forward
that was just work at it just figure out
so i knew i covered every angle that i
could on the court because i knew at
some point there was gonna be a position
i was gonna be in
and i didn't want that to be a weakness
and so you know the the
the the things that have been said about
ben uh the problems he's had in the
playoffs
it should sting enough
uh from this summer to hear about trade
talk to get him in the gym and just be
working on it and you know kind of
recreating
you know who he is re-evolving into uh a
a a different player because you know a
couple two years in the league figures
the game out and then they try and take
away your strong food so he's got to
start to evolve and adapt
when did you not
know how to shoot like one like when you
were three is that what it was right
like one
when did you not have a shot when was
that point
um
well i mean when i was a kid i always
loved put the ball in the basket but it
was difficult because
um i was just trying to figure out just
i had love for the game so i think more
than anything it's just trying to figure
out how to
to work at shooting because when i got
to college i've seen guys that were
better shooters than me and then they i
watched them how they shot
you know brian fair danielle marshall
scott burrell you know i watched those
three guys work out
and i said i i can't even do that you
know they they will go around the horn
and not miss a shot and i was like i'm
not that consistent and so i had to
learn that that that consistency
so it's just him
getting in the gym is what your
suggestion would be that just get in the
gym
in a way
yeah he's got to find
his niche
on the court and where he's comfortable
shooting posting up like working on that
just doing it till not until he gets it
right so he can't get it wrong you know
so when you get into a game like he's
comfortable taking that shot knocking it
down
ray allen here on the rich eisen show uh
so many people listening to us and
watching us right now ray uh either have
diabetes know somebody who has diabetes
or potentially like you are a parent to
a child um who was diagnosed with
diabetes it's 17 months old your son
walker's now 14. i will give you the
floor on on how um you are monitoring
your son and how
the technology from abbott is helping
well we're thankful because you know
walker he since he was diagnosed you
figured technology has
grown tremendously since 2008 and you're
you're thinking about all these things
that we can do with the cell phones and
you know all this this great technology
uh being able to dial up and order so
many different things and now
we partnered up with abbott and we have
this new freestyle library too
that allows us to check monitor his his
blood sugar uh on a daily basis so you
know right now
um
you know we just integrated into this uh
this new monitoring system and it has an
iphone app now so as we're sitting here
now we can
um we can look at his numbers while he's
at school so we don't have to
um
uh we don't have to sit here and wonder
what he is or run the school and and
check his fingers like right now you
know his number is 136.
and and that allows us to have more
uh
more ease of what dealing with his with
his diabetes so
uh for anybody who wants to know you
could um
the the freestyle library to iphone app
will be downloaded at the app store and
it's free
and uh if anybody wants more information
um you can get a free sample of the
freestyle library too and uh go on to
freestylery2.us
and um
if anybody wants more information but it
certainly made uh our
existence a lot a lot easier when
dealing with diabetes and and and it
gives a walker a sense of independence
love it freestyle
libre2.us he's 14. when do you plan on
showing him he got game right
when you play that [ __ ] to sell rich
well
wow yeah
okay
the whole thing like remember you gotta
remember everything they have access to
on youtube like i remember about four or
five years ago i come in a room he's got
his ipad and he's looking at all my
highlights so he's looking at my
highlight that means he's captaining the
uh google and everything pops up so he
sees it all
you know you can't hide anything from
these kids you say it you see it they
they they pull it up on on the internet
so um
you you all you can do is just kind of
just try to explain the situations and
and hope they understand it but you know
i think he got game
is one of those movies that
it means something different to you as a
kid and then when you go through your
teen years and then your your adult
years because
you some scenarios you don't understand
until you get in a situation like that
and then get past it and then you can
appreciate it more so
um it's one of those movies that's
something to spend knowledge to him over
the years has he uh asked you when when
do i go on my college visit dad
does he ask you that question
right
yeah
yeah
and and and you know because there's
four boys i got four of them okay
yeah my 17 year old is he's certainly
looking forward to it
you just remember we live in miami so oh
boy
okay don't take your kids on a boat out
in the key biscayne anytime soon and not
expect them to
uh be distracted by what's going on on
the water
man okay
yeah life comes at you fast there's no
question about that but here's the great
thing you know as a parent
you know now you you can get anything
you can that pull anything up on the
internet so you got to be willing to
have a conversation and not say oh wait
till you get older
yep you know it's a real live
conversation because if you don't
explain it to them then one of their
friends will i don't know i would
basically say get uncle spike on the
phone and explain it you know
pretty much oh my gosh have you um
ever spoken to spike lee about maybe
doing a reboot or some form of a he got
game two to see what jesus jesus christ
shuttlesworth is up to right now
yeah we we i see spike at least two or
three times a year and we talk about it
like with spike and i were at obama's
birthday party on the vineyard
and uh we sat at the same table we
we have exchanged so many different
ideas um
you know one one of the
the caveats was getting denzel back on
board and
um
that's been the struggle just trying to
convince him to
to jump back on and do part two so
um otherwise other than that we're gonna
have to figure out another way but you
know we we talk about it all the time so
you would totally be up for that right i
mean
what what do you where would jesus be
right now and you and spike's vision as
you're sitting there
um you know having a tray pass at the
obama's party you know so what is the
concept
that you can well i mean there's a
couple different angles uh but it always
involves a child of mine
and so
whether it's a boy or girl is the issue
but they kind of have next so kind of
like he or she got gained
and and obviously there's so much
subject matter
uh that that applies
that has we've dealt with over the last
15 20 years
that you can you can push into the
forefront especially when it comes to
sports
you know because right now we haven't
had a great sports movie
um that
that is real uh that involves
the professional aspect to the college
to the to the high school because right
now especially with nfts and nils
all these different
abbreviations
uh there's so much happening that that
changes it has changed the landscape of
sports
and um there's a human side to it you
know how does it affect the kids you
know what the kids are dealing with on
on college campuses nowadays
and even you look at the aau programs um
you know you know
kids that are great au don't end up good
in college you know they're
transferring it's just so much to talk
about and spike and i have had these
conversations so
you know it's gonna it's just i think
it's one of those things that when you
just a little bit of patience and i
think it's gonna happen um so we i'm
hoping that that happened all of us too
all of us too and ray
appreciate the time it's been too long
everybody should go to freestyle
libre2.us
to help uh battle diabetes and check on
it thanks for the call right really
appreciate it yeah thanks rich hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here